[Musique]
le droit et le tordu c'est le sous-titre
de cette émission vous savez c'est une
référence à la phrase de François
Mitterrand qui disait j'ai deux avocats
Robert bamaker pour le droit et lors
Dumas pour le tordu et vous allez voir
qu'il faut parfois être un peu tordus
pour faire du droit on va en parler mais
surtout peut-être qu'on fera référence à
cette fameuse formule de Jean Giraudoux
le droit est la plus puissante des
écoles de l'imagination et on va en
parler avec nos invités à travers deux
deux livres formidables
Nathalie Wolf bonjour bonjour Patrice
vous êtes maître de conférence à
l'Université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
et vous publiez avec l'oral maki mais
aussi avec Elsa Auriol et poncho vous
êtes mis à 4 mais on va voir pourquoi un
livre qui s'appelle des hommes des
femmes non libertés et qui revient sur
les droits de liberté et surtout aussi
sur les personnalités qui ont qui ont
mis ces droits à jour quoi alors je vous
présente tout de suite
vos deux coauteurs
qui est aussi la qui écrit avec vous et
puis et puis des formidable
illustrations qu'on doit Elsa Auriol
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
illustratifs vous êtes peintre
vous avez publié beaucoup beaucoup pour
la jeunesse notamment
alors il y a un des derniers ouvrages
voilà je le montre c'est où les cœurs
[Musique]
dernier dernier ouvrage s'appelle le
fakebook alors vos dessins politiques
c'est mais c'est 5 euros une certaine
actualité en temporelle je veux dire des
choses qui n'est pas vraiment dans la
société auquel reviennent alors j'ai mis
au début pas mal de seins sur la guerre
en Ukraine parce que c'est sorti un
joint et ça envoie Poutine
on va leur faire l'amour
et alors l'éditrices ou lui mettre aussi
des portraits que j'avais fait pour
regarder Londres
de Billie Holiday de Baltus ou de
portraits
il y a assez longtemps il y a quelques
années
au début
des protéines nostalgique des lumières
soviétiques j'ai l'avais fait en 2001 au
monde
en 2001
de la de la Russie il va être gentil il
va être très gentil il faut l'accueillir
dans l'Europe etc
vous vous avez illustré avec avec Elsa
auréole ce livre des hommes des femmes
de liberté et on peut dire aussi que la
liberté c'est quelque chose que vous
connaissez et la privation de liberté
aussi vous avez connu ça donc quelque
part parce que j'ai dû partir l'Uruguay
les pays où j'avais grandi que c'était
une démocratie c'était les pays les plus
démocratiques de l'Amérique du Sud ont
pensé jamais qu'il pouvait voir une
écriture il y a une dictature
73 et là je suis parti j'ai travaillé
dans presse qui était l'oppositions tous
les séjours là
on était fermé et alors oui on a
économie de la censure la prévention de
liberté mais je suis parti à temps parce
qu'après ça a été pire
des différents groupes au début et les
plus radicales
il est totalement
avec les syndicats avec les socialistes
pour les démocrates chrétiens tout le
monde je suis parti avant tout ça mais
c'était la privation de liberté pendant
12 ans et pas que il y a des disparus
et vous êtes arrivés en France en 83
c'est ça
l'Uruguay alors en Argentine
avec ma famille là de l'époque on est
parti au Venezuela quelques temps
quelques années et après on est venu en
France d'accord et voilà et donc oui non
je voulais simplement dire que le thème
de la liberté c'est pas que c'est pas
juste une idée pour vous voilà je
voulais te sucer une chose par rapport
au livre
des des libertés et on a fait des
portraits avec Elsa et les portraits en
couleur on était peint par Elsa il est
petit porteurs blancs c'est moi qui les
ai fait mais on va voir quelques heures
quand on va parler justement des
personnages par lesquels c'est c'est
liberté sont souvent des voilà donc on
va évidemment on parlait pendant
l'émission on va voir quelques-unes des
illustrations et d'Elsa et de vous alors
j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle je sais que
le Père Noël a été arrêté
quelques jours de quelques jours
quitter il était au télétravail à
Champigny-sur-Marne parce qu'ils avaient
un peu marre du Pôle Nord et là il y a
eu il y avait tellement de de de
flux sur
est-ce que le policier au thé alerté ils
ont arrêté le Père Noël c'est pas vrai
exactement c'est ce que je raconte et là
il faut le juger maintenant pour il faut
que tout ce qu'il a fait on va parler
c'est aussi un livre intelligent drôle
et
voilà et enrichissant c'est pas le
procès du Père Noël c'est aux éditions
Enric Bay j'ai oublié de préciser que
des femmes de liberté c'est chez Daloz
alors d'habitude c'est des guides c'est
des codes c'est de dire un peu alors
chaque année il publie un beau livre et
cette année c'est celui-là exactement on
a eu cette chance alors on va on va
parler de ce procédé du Père Noël en
effet je disais le Père Noël est arrêté
il y a il y a plein de griefs qui sont
retenus contre lui des charges qu'ils
ont retenu contre lui et puis il y a des
témoignages et puis ce procès s'ouvre
alors il va y avoir des témoignages il
va y avoir
plaidoirir etquisitoire on va en parler
tout de suite on va d'abord
de quoi accuse-t-on le Père Noël
[Musique]
alors
d'abord on va parler de cette
arrestation
vous avez jamais dessiné le Père Noël
il est arrêté qu'est-ce qu'il fait un
champignon vous dites pas que c'est sur
bam mais enfin comment c'est quand même
la ville de George marché oui en fait je
suis imaginé qu'il s'était installé là
en télétravail depuis le covid et ce qui
a alerté les autorités c'est cette
maison il a 8 en fait la cheminée est en
activité toute l'année donc ça a mis les
autorités sur une piste et se rendu
compte que le Père Noël travaillait
depuis Champigny en télétravail et donc
les on s'intéressant à son cas le
parquet a décidé de le poursuivre pour
pour toutes ces activités qui semblent
peut-être illégales absolument alors on
peut de quoi que dans le Père Noël le
premier premier infraction c'est la
violation de de domicile et de l'espace
et de l'espace aérien français
comme ça dans les boîtes ou trop faire
des spectacles en France et donc est-ce
que le Père Noël ne profite pas cette
situation de lutins qui ont beaucoup de
mal à travailler pour en fait
c'est très compliqué pour eux et leur
plateforme en plus pour pour trouver de
du travail qui s'appelle pôle Nord
emploi et très saturé donc c'est
vraiment difficile pour les lutins de
trouver du boulot exactement
donc et donc en plus il est loge ils
sont logés au Pôle Nord toutes les
conditions pas évident puisqu'ils sont
en collants avec le froid du Pôle Nord
et tout c'est est-ce que le la tenue de
travail adapté et donc pour le travail
forcé des lutins là ça va chercher
jusqu'à 15 ans de réclusion criminelle
donc c'est pour ça que c'est une cour
d'assis qui est juste le Père Noël et ce
qui est voilà et et on verra qui sont
mesurés dans un instant mais ce qui est
très drôle et vous y référence au lancer
de nain c'est à dire que il y a des
références il y a des arrêts de de de
cours enfin donc on appelle de de
juridiction constante dans dans votre
travail au-delà de l'humour voilà il y a
des il y a des évidemment juridique
quatrième troisième infraction c'est
acte du cruauté envers les rênes
totalement et là c'est pareil c'est
trois ans de emprisonnement et jusqu'à
45000 euros d'amende aussi parce qu'il
les fait quand même travailler 24 heures
et plus même avec les décalage horaire
donc certes c'est c'est une seule
journée mais bon c'est bon on verra
voilà voilà la défense qui dit oui
d'accord 24 ans pour faire il travaille
15 jours par an quoi effectivement
qui a le il y a une sorte de clignotant
aussi
la question des manipulations génétiques
sur les reines aussi
et puis quatrième catégorie d'infraction
c'est la livraison de de jouer
contrefaits ou défectueux oui celle-ci
c'était la plus étrange parce que je
crois qu'on a on n'a jamais vraiment
réalisé que les enfants commandent des
jouets sur des catalogues les jouets
sont fabriqués par donc pas je parle
LEGO avec burger Matel et le Père Noël
fabrique lui ensuite ces mêmes jouets et
les livres donc il y a une contrefaçon
des jouets qui sont conçus par d'autres
marques et c'est le Père Noël qui les
refabrique et ensuite il y a la
livraison des jouets dangereux et là en
faisant des recherches je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait plein de jouets qui
étaient souvent retirés de la vente
parce que soit ils étaient dangereux
pour les enfants soyez beaucoup de
blessés j'ai même trouvé une boîte de un
petit kit de petits chimiste qui a été
retiré de la vente aux États-Unis dans
les années 60 parce qu'il y avait un
matériel radioactif dedans en fait donc
substance ou pas et cette même marque
avait aussi fait une boîte de bricoleur
avec une vraie scie sauteuse pour les
petits garçons donc il y a eu des doigts
coupés et donc voilà et ça c'est le Père
Noël qui le livre quand même et donc il
est un peu complice de tout ça alors
c'est parce que la Cour va devoirs oui
parce que voilà parce que il faut
expliquer donc il est arrêté il y a
c'est c'est chef d'accusation qui sont
retenus contre lui après on va on va en
parler d'ailleurs il va y avoir des
témoignages évidemment il y a une
enquête et puis il y aura un procès et
ce sont les lecteurs du livre qui sont
au fond les jurés tirés au sort et qui
vont devoir dire si condam ou pas le le
Père Noël mais alors on avance pas alors
il y a il y a des
qui a dit non pas c'est pas possible le
Père Noël c'est le Père Noël
donc il y a des affaires comme ça en
France il y a cette affaire là du Père
Noël qui avait cette partie enfin qui
est parti dans centre commercial avec la
caisse en buvant de la bière et en
suivant peut-être pas que des cigarettes
devant les enfants dans le centre
commercial et
ensuite il y a aussi tous les quand même
les antécédents administratifs et là ils
sont plutôt favorables au Père Noël
c'est tous les arrêtés municipaux qui
ont été adoptés récemment pour pour que
les gens en fait des Blaze leur jardin
efface un peu de place pour le traîneau
accueille les lutins et tout ça c'est
des vrais arrêtés municipaux qui ont été
pris en France il a peut-être 5 ou 6
maintenant après le covid c'était les
maires qui voulaient un peu certifié aux
enfants juridiquement que le Père Noël
existe donc donc il y en a encore un qui
a été adopté il y a quelques quelques
jours dans la commune de ben j'ai plus
du tout le long c'est pas très grave il
y en a quand même
alors donc il y a les chefs d'accusation
il y a il y a les antécédents et il y a
le témoignage
la Mère Noël qui est plutôt sympa
bon type quoi le Père Noël
le procès c'est cinq jours de témoignage
donc le lecteur va te lire les les cinq
journées le premier jour c'est les
proches du Père Noël donc c'est la mère
Noël et les lutins démission qui a
démissionné pour burn out et un lutin
qui est toujours en poste et donc là ils
expliquent un peu leur condition de
travail et puis
moi je travaille depuis plus de 100 ans
c'est le patron des lutins
je dois aller plus de 100 ans depuis
plus de 100 ans pour lui c'est un
honneur c'est formidable voilà mais il y
en a un autre qui dit pas du tout
évidemment c'est le responsable de la
fabrication des jeux qui vous disent ça
mais mais
c'est bien pire que nos conditions de
travail sont terribles quoi il y en a un
mais c'est ça les gens ils parlent cette
histoire de collant ensuite c'est très
dur d'être enfin comme tous ensemble
toute l'année on peut c'est très
difficile puis permet les palais
puisqu'il est à Champigny donc c'est
géré par des lutins qui sont là depuis
plus longtemps et tout c'est assez
difficile les conditions de vie des
lutins mais est-ce que ça constitue un
travail forcé c'est c'est pas donc c'est
une des questions
et il y a aussi il y a aussi un
interprète des rêves qui vient témoigner
parce que qu'est-ce qu'ils pensent les
règles et et moi
comment on est certes de feu de
croisement ça me met égal quoi
donc il y a ça d'abord il y a les
proches après il y a les
célébrités personnalité c'est très drôle
il y a Carl Lagerfeld par exemple qui
était bloqué qui dit le Père Noël c'est
rouge c'est moche ça te va avec rien
mais ça peut vous sauver l'enfance
est-ce qu'il avait dit sur le gilet
jaune évidemment
alors Vladimir Poutine est très copain
avec le Père Noël oui ou qu'il vient
témoigne au procès lui apporter son
soutien en visio puisqu'il peut pas il
préfère pas se rendre
dans une course française et en fait
c'est c'est parce qu'il y a une vraie
affaire en Russie avec un avocat de
Saint-Pétersbourg qui a porté plainte
contre la société russe qui gère le
village du Père Noël et il estime que
depuis qu'il est enfant il est envoyé
des listes de cadeaux à cette société
comme les gens voient en France à
Libourne par la poste leur liste au Père
Noël et il a jamais reçu les cadeaux
donc il a porté plainte contre cette
société en donc l'année dernière et
Poutine a été interrogé là-dessus en
conférence de presse il y a 2 ans et il
a dit que l'avocat du Père Noël c'était
lui donc il allait prendre sa défense en
France
rien n'est inventé là et donc d'accord
ils ont proposé enfin il voulait qu'il
voulait le professeur notre nom etc
alors du coup ça c'est en fait dans le
livre on apprend aussi le la tradition
du Père Noël en Russie qui est
différente de la du Père Noël français
déjà il habillé en bleu il s'appelle
différemment donc Poutine explique tout
ça mais il explique aussi cette vraie
affaire gel hein
et donc il se balade en calèche en
traîneau avec des rennes et Poutine
raconte cette affaire il explique que si
c'est avocat n'a pas eu de cadeaux il a
qu'à s'en prendre qu'à lui-même ce qu'il
a pas été assez sage donc pour l'instant
on n'a pas encore eu le jugement dans la
ferme mais tout ça tout est vrai toutes
les déclarations Poutine sont vraies
j'ai dit ouais en plus le rouge quand
même ça va pas chez nous c'est le
couleur du Coca-Cola et puis ça fait sa
grosse ici donc ça c'est de la publicité
pour l'obésité les Américains et ça
c'est peut-être mais oui mais oui donc
on apprend un peu l'histoire du Père
Noël russe en fait dans le livre
j'essaie de présenter le
soit le droit autrement en voyant mais
aussi le père Noël autrement et le Père
Noël c'est pour ça que c'est très drôle
après il y a aussi les les experts
respectent du travail qui dit l'atelier
de l'atelier du lutins et loin d'être
aux normes c'est vrai
c'est pas c'est pas terrible le
vétérinaire alors c'est lui qui dit
reine travaille beaucoup mais enfin il
travaille que 24 heures
en fait du coup je me suis basé sur une
vraie thèse vétérinaire sur les reines
enfin Noël donc elle a un rapport
évidemment tout ça tout ça et mon
beau-père est en vétérinaire je vais
demander beaucoup de conseils c'est lui
en fait qui est le vétérinaire de
exactement qui va au Pôle Nord et qui
écrit son son expertise et il y a aussi
une expertise de médecin qui font l'état
de santé du Père Noël
depuis longtemps hein complètement et
alors ça c'est basé sur une vraie étude
de l'universitaire de de médecin de la
faculté de la chambre de l'USQ qui ont
fait le dossier médical du Père Noël qui
sont qui ont vu qu'elle pouvait ces
pathologies médicales en fonction de ces
conditions de travail et c'est hyper
intéressant par exemple il explique
qu'il devrait avoir un cancer de la peau
et un mélanome depuis longtemps puisque
le traîneau évoluant au dessus de
l'atmosphère il y a pas l'atmosphère qui
bloque les rayons cosmiques donc il
devrait développer un cancer aussi
d'important problème de peau et de Sud
il fait sa distribution le 25 décembre
en tenue de pôle Nord mais dans
l'hémisphère sud il fait chaud c'est
l'été donc du coup c'est pas du tout
adapté
comme ça puis aussi des problèmes mais
après de surpoids d'obésité de diabète
et tout puisque dans chaque maison il
prend un verre et puis des cookies et
d'alcoolisme aussi dans certains pays
c'est pas un peu d'alcool ouais c'est un
peu d'alcool dans la Chine et donc tant
qu'on pensait que c'était les parents
qui qui buvaient ce petit verre de
cognac dans les pays anglo-saxons qui
est dans la cheminée ça allait mais
maintenant qu'on sait que le Père Noël
existe vraiment et qu'il les voit tous
ça pose quand même un problème et aussi
sur le l'état de d'alcoolémie quand il
conduit le traîneau oui c'est ça parce
qu'il conduit en état alcoolémie
et alors il y a alors ça vous on peut
tous en parler il y a aussi les
psychanalystes
prépare les enfants au futur castration
sociale c'est-à-dire que c'est vrai que
à 6 ans ou 7 ans quand on apprend que
peut-être pas sûr
c'est vrai que ça peut ça peut non moi
j'aurais une question
le Père Noël est censé apporter les
cadeaux à partir de minuit donc beaucoup
d'enfants guettent minuit pour avoir les
cadeaux mais comment on fait le Père
Noël pour aminer être distribuer tous
les cadeaux à minuit après alors c'est
grâce au décalage horaire
salut laisse en fait un peu plus 24
heures mais là ça pose problème
d'ailleurs dans le procès parce qu'il y
a un dispositif spécial anti magie du
Père Noël pour qu'il soit dans le box
des accusés
qui puisse passer grâce au lutin tout a
été vraiment pensé par cette course
spéciale et alors je si tu te feras des
psychanalyses qui ont fait rire des
parents obligent l'enfant à rentrer dans
une logique phallique du Père Noël qui
passe par le cheminée qui représente
évidemment le phallus à l'issue duquel
a-t-on le lait
alors là j'ai pris je dois être honnête
aussi j'ai confronté un peu à toutes les
sciences et aussi au pseudo-science avec
la psychanalyse j'ai pris quelques
articles sont absolument lunaires et
donc j'en ai fait un témoignage de
psychanalyste inventé qui s'appelle
Jacqueline lacanque du coup
donc voilà mais alors c'est complètement
à patchwork de ce que j'ai pu lire de
sur les interprétations psychanalytiques
du Père Noël et donc voilà c'est un
autre témoignage d'expert et il y a
aussi les risques disent les
psychanalyses le mythe du Père Noël
s'écroule environ à l'âge de 7 ans
c'est-à-dire à la fin du stade phallique
justement complètement
c'est terrible c'est vrai que non mais
c'est vrai que c'est une question que
tous les parents est-ce qu'il faut
est-ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faut
parler du Père Noël enfin
tout le monde est ravi quand même non
je suis pas sûr que les Père Noël de
supermarché ça fasse beaucoup pour le
pour la légende et j'ai l'impression
d'en avoir un peu moins mais je sais pas
peut-être que je suis molle
prochainement
toute la journée
alors donc il y a ce procès on en vient
au réquisitoire du procureur à la fin
donc à la fin on peut donner les
répétitions
de réclusion criminelle avec 10 ans de
période de sûreté durant laquelle ne
pourra pas demander d'aménagement de
peine 500000 € d'amende et enfin
concernant le dédommagement des victimes
2500 euros par enfant puisque
l'association qui a produit de calcul à
estime à 5000 euros le montant inversé
par enfant
des parties civils qui viennent donc une
association victime de Noël qui
représente tous les enfants victimes de
ces jouets
défectueux en fait
10 ans disons de sûreté quand même on va
13 ans c'est beaucoup quand même
l'intérêt de l'enfant l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant est abîmée et
l'avocate l'avocate dit à quitter le
Père Noël ou vous n'oserez plus jamais
regarder en face vos enfants le 25
décembre au matin lorsque le sapin ne
trouvera plus à son pied un seul cadeau
c'est la réquisition finale de l'avocate
donc la fin de la plaidoirie et ensuite
il faut passer au vote
a priori comme ça vous a quitteriez ou
qu'on donne Noël Elsa
alors
en fait ce qu'on vraiment dans le livre
le lecteur est placé en position de juré
donc à la fin il y a un QR code il se
connecte aussi du livre en fait c'est
lui qui vote absolument pour décider de
la culpabilité du Père Noël en fait
j'essaie de refaire un peu ce que
faisait Robert Hossein sur scène elles
ont voté le public à la fin bon c'était
des reconstitutions de process
historiques mais là c'est un peu le même
concept donc et donc les lecteurs les
jurés par contre décident très
précisément si les coupables donc pas
pour chacun des chefs d'incubation est
fixe ensuite la peine prison ferme ou
avec sursis c'est aussi une possibilité
on peut quand même condamner à prix
juste à la prison avec sursis pour
pouvoir laisser libre enfin en liberté
pour qu'ils puissent distribuer les
cadeaux cette année et ensuite on peut
fixer l'amende et décider des mesures
complémentaires donc soit le l'indemnité
pour les enfants et aussi si jamais il
est coupable de dacte envers les rênes
le placement des reines à la SPA
mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait un vrai
débat dans les dans les pièces de Robert
Hossein c'est à dire que à chaque fois
par exemple toujours été acquitté par
exemple parler enfin les gens qui
regardaient la pièce et moi avec un
copain qui était critique de théâtre on
se disait mais c'est idiot il faut voter
la mort c'est le seul moyen c'est le
seul endroit où on peut voter la mort de
quelqu'un
[Rires]
sauf évidemment rien risquer enfin cette
personne
disait qu'à chaque fois parce que la fin
de la pièce changeait en fonction du
résultat du vote mais il était toujours
identique le résultat était toujours
interdit que c'était toujours la kit bon
enfin je sais que Marie-Antoinette
n'était jamais été condamné par exemple
les autres procès historiques
toujours le c'est toujours le même sens
je me rappelle mais là non faut voir
donc du coup il y a pas la fin du il y a
pas le jugement il y a pas le jugement
là il faut il faut aller jusqu'au bout
de l'expérience et voter et ensuite
valider son vote et là on a accès au
résultat de des autres lecteurs donc
pour l'instant je ça vient de commencer
donc on sait pas tellement encore
mais c'est un vrai un vrai procès
populaire un vrai procès voilà donc
c'est c'est voilà c'est c'est un moyen
de de parler du droit de manière ludique
amusante et et non et passionnante parce
que c'est vrai que ce qu'on disait il y
a toutes les références à des arrêts à
des textes de loi non c'est bien c'est
marrant hein je trouve ça passionnant je
découvre et je suis émerveillée c'est
original et puis en plus je viens
d'apprendre vous avez étudié dans dans
la faculté où j'enseigne et je me dis
mais c'est super
étudiants
en plus donc c'est en lien avec le les
deux livres avec les deux livres avec
des amis incroyable
c'est bien sympa les ordinateurs on les
voit noter puis on imagine pas que
finalement tout ce qui se met en place
moi je suis ravie merci alors le voyage
au cœur des combats pour nos droits et
de nos libertés avec ce livre on va
parler des libertés des hommes des
femmes nos libertés
[Musique]
alors
c'est vrai que c'est alors c'est là
aussi c'est
un livre qui est à la portée de tous pas
c'est pas fait c'est fait des juristes
peuvent aussi lire c'est ça que vous
avez voulu faire enfin on espère on a
on a fait un peu découvrir le droit
aussi au grand public on dit toujours
nul n'est censé ignorer la loi et
finalement on se rend compte que on la
connaît pas bien et vraiment c'est cette
envie là qui nous a porté tous les
quatre c'est de rendre accessible le
droit et surtout nos grandes libertés
nos droits de l'homme qu'on dont on
jouit tous les jours certaines sont
fragilisées limitées mais de les
comprendre c'est c'est vraiment
l'objectif premier de ce livre oui c'est
la liberté d'expression c'est la liberté
d'aller devenir sa liberté de disposer
de son corps enfin toutes les libertés
et alors comment est venue l'idée de
travailler
et le rêve maquillage avec vous et alors
vous avez déjà travaillé avec Elsa on a
déjà travaillé ensemble avec Elsa sur
des algues jeunesse et avec Pancho aussi
sur un album qui s'appelle Dracula et
moi que Pancho avait participé à la
l'illustration avec Elsa donc on a déjà
travaillé ensemble on se connaît déjà
comment oui comment on se dit tiens on
va illustrer un livre sur les libertés
en soit comme ça c'est pas évident quand
on dit ça comme ça oui c'est ça alors
c'est parti de voilà tout est à la
Faculté de Droit donc les cours mes
cours sur les sur les libertés
fondamentales donc l'envie comme on l'a
dit de faire connaître le droit au grand
public et puis avec Laura elle maquille
on avait monté un séminaire il y a déjà
pas mal d'années de droits et de
littérature
où on a commencé un dialogue on a voulu
montrer comment et bien tous les
artistes les écrivains au fond on
façonné nos grands droits donc tout est
parti de là on a voulu ensuite
poursuivre ce dialogue avec Laura
racontée donc cette histoire des
libertés et ce qui ce qui est important
pour nous c'est d'essayer de montrer au
fond quelles sont les hommes et les
femmes derrière nos grands textes voilà
il y a plein de grands textes on a
déclaration de droits de l'homme on
allait la liberté d'aller venir on a le
droit à l'éducation la liberté
d'expression etc et quels sont les
hommes et les femmes qui ont œuvré pour
que ces droits existent et pour qu'on
puisse aujourd'hui et bien s'exprimer
ne pas en a parlé de la peine de mort
elle va donner
de la liberté alors juste pour répondre
Patrice à votre question en fait pour
incarner ces hommes et femmes pour que
ces hommes et femmes et de la chair pour
qu'ils existent vraiment il fallait les
peindre et les illustrés voilà j'admire
beaucoup le travail d'Elsa et voilà
c'était une évidence
de ces figures de la liberté justement
alors voilà
vous pouvez compter ça c'est un arabe et
ça c'est c'est Elsa
en couleur et donc voilà Anna arène on a
toujours l'image d'une femme déjà d'un
âge un petit peu avancé dans sa maturité
et voilà moi j'ai voulu montrer une
Arendt la jeune femme la jeune la jeune
fille même qu'elle était et qui déjà
portait en elle c'est combat là donc
avant d'être la femme qu'elle a été elle
a été cette jeune femme et
voilà
pour cette
banalisation du mal c'est ça
[Musique]
expulsée d'Allemagne donc par les nazis
donc il y a une juive allemande qui va
se réfugier d'abord enfin qui va venir
en France qui va ensuite être exilé aux
États-Unis qui d'ailleurs restera à
Patrick ça aussi c'est intéressant donc
elle est vraiment la figure pour nous de
la liberté de pas de l'exil et c'est
vrai qu'elle a beaucoup réfléchi
les totalitarisme
[Musique]
n'est totalement responsable de ce qui
se passe
il y a celui qui amène le gaz et celui
qui amène le qui qui fait en sorte que
le train soit à l'heure ce qui fait que
personne ne se sent directement
responsable du du du de la barbarie quoi
c'est ça en partie d'autre part c'est
les problèmes c'est les gens qui
s'habituent ça et c'est prête à ça parce
que tout le monde voulait faire oui
c'est ce qu'on fait et alors on y va et
c'est un des dangers que je crois que je
vise un peu exister qui peut exister
aujourd'hui justement comme on a la
tentation
de chercher l'homme fort l'homme ma
femme forte et l'énergie autoritaire et
on s'est prête à permettre que ça existe
on est comme ça
on peut peut-être regarder un deuxième
le visage de
alors le quiz qui est-ce que vous
je le connaissais pas du tout
les juristes le connaissent parce que
c'est un peu le fondateur d'une drop
pénal moderne pour dire ça comme ça
enfin pour aller vite
mais c'est pas il est connu peut-être en
Italie plus que plus qu'en France mais
en France c'est vrai qu'à part le cercle
des juristes
le premier à
lutter contre la peine de mort dont on
parlait à l'instant donc c'est un prix
curseur
mais voilà le premier qui a lutter
contre ça et qui s'est beaucoup inspiré
de monter ce que comme il a beaucoup lui
Montesquieu aussi sur la modération de
la peine il va y avoir aussi des lettres
qui vont être écrites entre eux
au délit enfin
en tout cas c'est très émouvant d'avoir
des hommes comme ça on se dit mais voilà
c'est très difficile parce qu'on est
obligé de se documenter nous avec plein
de choses notre notre volonté c'était
d'être fidèle d'être fidèle à ces
figures tout en mettant notre propre
interprétation et bah oui quand on a
César Beccaria César arrive et Carya à
dessiner il y a pas de photos à l'époque
il y a pas de photos
voilà donc il faut on se réfère à des
peintures
on se réfère à des peintures et des
peintures qui voilà qui sont pas en
grand nombre donc j'ai eu très très peu
d'éléments pour pour ces arrêts Beccaria
voilà donc j'ai essayé de faire avec ce
que j'avais trouvé et la plupart des
choses qui avaient sur lui c'est assez
sombre enfin général peinture assez
sombre et donc moi j'avais volonté
justement de faire quelque chose de très
clair voilà d'être dans la clarté
c'était le fil conducteur de tous mes
portraits mais voilà quand on quand on
portraitiste quelqu'un on sent un peu
l'âme de la personne on sent si c'est
quelqu'un de bons et il fait partie de
oui on peut dire
il fait partie de ces portraits où on
sent la bonté dans la personne quoi
c'est pour ça que j'ai un attachement
particulier ce portrait là et bien sûr
la peine de mort on pense toujours à
Robert banater mais on y a des
précurseurs voilà comme disait
je crois que vous le citez doucement
la France est le dernier pays à
maintenir la peine de mort
oui en Europe bien sûr mais c'est vrai
que c'est un peu grand-père de en fait
ce qu'on a voulu montrer aussi dans ce
livre c'est un peu c'est les filiation
c'est vraiment ça qui nous a intéressé
on a essayé de créer ça
évidemment
à quel point ça a été difficile on
imagine à cette époque là parce que ça
à une époque voilà au 18e siècle c'est
ça devait être fallait être costaud je
pense hein
évidemment c'est une nouvelle le droit
de disposer de son corps c'est c'est un
rapport la loi sur l'IVG exactement et
oui c'est vrai que voilà la question du
corps des femmes est très présente dans
dans le livre mais pas pas seulement du
corps des femmes du corps en général et
c'est vrai que ce sont souvent le voilà
d'abord le corps des femmes qui a été
malmené dans l'histoire qui est un objet
dans la véritablement politique et on a
on a des figures assez classiques
maintenant pourrait-on dire
Simone Veil son combat pour le droit
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
qui d'ailleurs en France et heureusement
beaucoup mieux protégé et assez assez
bien d'ailleurs même s'il y a encore
passer dans la Constitution oui moi je
suis un peu un peu un peu un peu étonné
de voir ces débats là parce que on a on
a on a cette question qui se pose bien
sûr aux États-Unis et le droit était
absolument malmené et c'est la remise en
cause des États-Unis par la Cour suprême
quand même exactement mais aux
États-Unis
c'est un droit qui est posé avec
beaucoup de fragilité quand il existe
même si il est aujourd'hui remise en
cause
on va parvenir de il y a peu de risques
qu'on vienne dessus en France enfin
heureusement en France c'est un droit
qui est de mieux en mieux protégé
d'ailleurs cette l'année dernière on a
porté de 12 à 14 semaines le délai pour
procéder à un avortement puisque il faut
voilà il suffit pas de consacrer un
droit mais il faut le rendre concret et
ça fait partie de la concrétisation des
choses et heureusement en France il est
de mieux en mieux protéger ce droit donc
moi j'ai l'impression que c'est un débat
qui enfin j'ai l'impression que le
Parlement pourrait se centrer sur
d'autres choses sur qui qui sont
vraiment fragilisés j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit un sujet noté
par le Sénat donc je pense qu'il y a
d'autres sujets de de droit des libertés
à mon avis à
qui qui sont vraiment fragilisés je
crois pas qu'en France et heureusement
d'ailleurs je crois pas qu'en français
ça c'est il faut dire que
magnifique magnifique dessin aussi c'est
pas non c'est pas toi
mais magnifique boule de d'oreilles de
Sigman Weil
c'est important c'est c'est très
important et c'est un peu monitoire et
non j'ai
ayant vécu ce que je vécu auparavant
dans un pays où on croyait pas que les
choses pouvaient changer et j'ai
tout un peu plus pessimiste que
que
ça peut arriver
en France l'histoire un gouvernement
autoritairement dans quelques années qui
puisse mettre en cause l'abolition de la
peine des morts et puis se mettre encore
en cause les droits à l'avortement on
n'est pas à l'abri
aujourd'hui alors je sais pas si vous
revenez enfin il y a dans le
gouvernement italien des gens qui sont
absolument contre la contre le droit à
l'avortement notamment je sais pas si
quand même ce qui nous protège en France
par rapport à tous ces pays
c'est la laïcité c'est notre modèle un
particulier et grâce à ce principe qui
lui aussi est fragilisé malheureusement
mais c'est aussi ce qui permet en
séparant de religieux du politique de se
protéger justement de ces tentatives de
fragilisation et c'est pas la même chose
en Italie c'est pas la même chose aux
États-Unis c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on
est un peu
pourquoi
c'est le dernier chapitre déjà notre
livre on a terminé ce livre sur un droit
qui nous est vraiment cherche je crois
que je peux parler au nom de tous les
trois et de Laura quatrième qui n'est
pas là aujourd'hui mais le droit à
l'intimité il nous semble que c'est l'un
des droits qui est les plus fragilisés
aujourd'hui
avec les fragilisations j'ai
l'impression qu'elles viennent pas tant
de l'État même si elles existent il y a
la vidéo surveillance il y a quand même
il y en a beaucoup à dire mais on a
quand même l'impression que c'est encore
plus insidieux que ça parce que au fond
on a un certain nombre de grandes
entreprises les gafams et
révéler mon livre Facebook au début
c'était justement pour
aller
complotisme et tout ce qui est je suis
pas contre je suis pas dans les
ressources sociaux mais je veux dire
c'est bien que ça existe mais les
problèmes c'est les effets secondaires
des et la façon j'avais fait dans un
autre livre possédant
un dessin que c'était une personnage qui
parlait au lecteur et que vissé cette
espèce de bande dessinée qui disait que
et dans notre société les gens qui sont
condamnés à porter un bracelet
électronique ça permet de connaître les
moments ça va où ils sont à tout moment
aux États etc et ils sont condamnés
utilisés ça et la personne décée vous
savez un téléphone portable et ça permet
aussi de partout et savoir des en plus
votre vos emails vous appelez
téléphoniques vos SMS c'est bien plus se
fait dire que un bracelet
personne ne vous a condamné vous êtes
condamné toute seule et vous avez
[Musique]
incroyable dans les enquêtes policiers
aujourd'hui on trouve toute une
traçabilité des portables permet de
savoir s'il est de faire ça comme
personne de enfin si voilà si vous
voulez commettre un bon délit il faut
séparez-vous de votre portable
on les dit pas trop mais conversations
moi je trouve qu'il nous regarde il nous
met en garde et ce dessin
peut peut-être s'éviter les sociétés
qu'il avait connu mais il faut être
vigilance ça dépendez-vous
tous ça dépend de nous
autres visage on en a quelques-uns on a
pris quelques temps alors oui alors ça
c'est aussi un dessin poncho et c'est
mon frère
exactement et c'est Kaby que ça me
touchait spécialement faire son côté
parce que on se connaissait depuis très
longtemps c'est voyez tous les enduits
mais en particulier les changer avec lui
je n'aurais jamais imaginé que vous
pouvez finir comme ça
oui c'est vrai que là aussi c'est vrai
que c'est un droit
dont on pouvait penser qu'il était
acquis la liberté d'expression dans un
pays comme la France et on a vu
en 2015
c'était pas aussi simple que ça oui ce
qui est intéressant c'est ça c'est que
pendant tout l'Ancien Régime on va dire
qu'on est pour résumer sous le régime de
la censure à partir de la Révolution
française mais surtout à partir de la
loi de 18 80 sur la liberté de la presse
la liberté est consacrée c'est un des
régimes les plus libéraux en France
qu'on est sur la liberté d'expression et
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui ça rejoint un
petit peu ce qu'on vient de dire sur le
l'intimité et le droit au respect de la
vie privée la censure elle est plutôt
étatique que
qu'instidieux et venant de groupe dans
la société qui peuvent être des groupes
économiques des groupes religieux des
groupes qui veulent aussi limiter la
liberté puisqu'on a des artistes ici
des groupes qui veulent limiter aussi la
liberté de création artistique on le
voit dans la littérature dans la chanson
dans le dans le dans le théâtre dans le
cinéma et bien sûr la question du
blasphème aujourd'hui et la question de
la religion très prégnante qui fait que
certains vont empêcher et bien les
dessinateurs de presse les journalistes
de faire leur métier au nom de la
défense d'une religion de la religion et
c'est et c'est très très pro c'est très
inattendu ça montre que rien n'est
jamais acquis
la question des caricatures de Charlie a
posé le problème très nettement même
si oui mais au début ça s'est réglé au
tribunal
c'est ensuite qu'il y a eu les voilà les
attentats et non oui enfin on a vu
monter les choses quand même à partir de
la fin des années 80 mais ce qui ce qui
est terrible aujourd'hui
ce qui est terrible aujourd'hui moi ce
que je crains c'est que finalement les
intellectuels et les artistes et puis
finalement les enseignants et puis tout
un chacun finisse par s'auto censurer et
j'espère qu'on arrivera pas à ça
est-ce que par exemple quand elles a
peut-être moins parce que vous êtes
moins dans le dessin de
ça vous arrive de vous dire non
et c'est que
c'est que je vécu un Uruguay avant la
dictature
des limitations des garanties
universelle et tout cela c'était l'état
des sièges qui Costa-Gavras a filmé dans
un film c'était un Uruguay c'était sur
la alors déjà il y avait la censure il
est déjà j'étais dessinateur de presse
j'avais la responsabilité
hebdomadaire qui fait avec la place du
monde
de la société uruguayenne alors il
fallait continuer à dire des choses
et même s'il y avait la censure de façon
que les publics les lecteurs puissent
les comprendre alors on ne sait pas tout
mais on jouait avec
d'autres façons de le lire mais oui oui
c'était auto-censure entre guillemets
les choses mais il fallait dire d'une
façon que la publication ne puisse pas
être fermée
alors on va on va se s'interroger
peut-être un dernier un dernier alors
voilà le visage
je crois que qui vous est cher Nathalie
oui j'aime beaucoup cet écrivain
algérien qui vient en Algérie qui a qui
est également journaliste et qui a écrit
des livres magnifiques notamment
Meursault contre-enquête voilà qui est
un livre qui raconte
reprend le livre d'Albert Camus
l'étranger mais vu par celui qui est
décrit dans l'étranger comme l'arabe et
donc lui va va reprendre ce livre mais
avec les yeux de
qui s'appelle là voilà exactement donc
c'est c'est un très grand écrivain et
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui évolue
dans sa pensée qui a qui a dans les au
début
était plutôt liés à des à des théories
plutôt islamistes et qui a beaucoup
évolué justement et qui aujourd'hui est
un des grands défenseurs de de la
laïcité de du corps des femmes de la
libération du corps des femmes notamment
en Algérie il écrit toutes les semaines
dans dans le point des chroniques qui
sont passionnantes et il fait partie
parmi beaucoup d'autres figures parce
que voilà il y a beaucoup d'étudiants
possibles mais c'était bien de défenseur
du du
siècle de siècle des Lumières
aujourd'hui pardon qui est intéressant
par rapport à
lui c'est mon exemplaire
c'est qu'il y a des droits libertés qui
sont un peu moins traités comme le droit
à l'environnement sain ou à l'éducation
aussi ça c'est vraiment super et là il y
a le droit l'environnement en effet ce
qui est aussi une liberté c'est vrai oui
vous avez raison c'est vrai qu'on se
concentre souvent sur les des notamment
sur les libertés d'expression du coup
c'est vraiment accessible à tout enlever
et même pour les juristes on découvre
différemment d'autres droits et tout moi
j'ai beaucoup aimé Kafka et tous les
participants même entrées qui a pas
parlé du Père Noël mais qui aurait pu
intervenir dans le procès du Père Noël
question pour terminer le droit est-il
partout
[Musique]
je reviens peut-être
vous distinguez on l'a dit des
catégories de liberté parce que vous en
parliez justement le droit à
l'environnement mais donc on parlait de
la liberté d'expression la liberté
d'aller devenir la liberté de disposer
de son corps
alors c'est vrai qu'on peut les
distinguer mais au fond est-ce que la
liberté c'est pas un tout quand même je
me disais est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir un
pays où on n'aurait pas
la liberté d'expression mais on pourrait
avoir la liberté d'aller devenir non
tout est dit quand même non ah c'est une
question difficile toutatrice que vous
nous posez mais en effet c'est vrai je
vois pas un pays qui pourrait
restreindre juste une liberté et si on
restera une on restera les autres il me
semble non
c'est le moment
de la liberté sont confisquées on peut
pas dire que c'est une guerre on peut
pas on peut rien dire on peut pas dire
qu'on est contre Poutine voilà tout est
au contraire les religions
de toute façon elles se font écho elles
sont vraiment en permanence en équilibre
c'est un jeu de c'est une dialectique et
c'est comme Apple aussi ce qu'on a voulu
montrer dans ce livre
tous ces hommes et ces femmes se
répandent toutes ces libertés et ses
droits se répond et on a la chance d'en
payer dans lequel on vit d'avoir quand
même même si il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à améliorer on a
parlé de la dignité des personnes
détenues enfin il y a beaucoup de de
faire aussi sur le plan d'éducation sur
le droit à l'environnement mais quand
même on a un certain nombre de liberté
qui existent aussi
parce qu'elles sont toutes ensemble il y
a la liberté d'expression parce que il y
a aussi la laïcité et la question du
blasphème il y a la question par exemple
de du droit à l'éducation parce qu'il y
a l'égalité et l'égalité aussi entre les
enfants riches et les enfants pauvres
les garçons les filles etc tout ça ça
fonctionne ensemble et dès qu'on bouge
un élément du puzz c'est très très
déstabilise notre notre socle des
libertés
de de les traiter différents mais je
crois que tout va en soi j'ai mis une
deuxième question quand même parce que
on pourrait dire ah oui et vous avez
raison il est sa teinte à certaines
libertés il faut faire attention
et en même temps là on voit dans ces
derniers mois qui est une formidable
aspiration à la liberté je pense à
l'Iran je pense à la Chine ce qui se
passe on est en Chine je sais pas si ça
aboutira peu importe mais on voit qu'il
y a quand même c'est un espoir pendant
la jeunesse une immense inspiration à
liberté que quand les jeunes Chinois ont
vu que
alors qu'ils sont cloîtrés à cause de
cette politique imbécile du Zéro covid
ils ont vu que la Coupe du monde de
football il y avait des stades plein
avec des gens qui étaient les uns à côté
des autres et qu'on pouvait faire ça ça
voilà c'est marrant
la revendication de liberté viennent du
Qatar mais enfin
mais mais non mais c'est vrai il y a
quand même au seau quoi dans les peuples
une formida c'est ça c'est très
encourageant non vous trouvez pas oui
parce que c'est c'est humain en fait
c'est juste humain parce que être privé
de liberté c'est pas naturel c'est c'est
aller contre les lents de vie en fait
peut-être que dans un monde connecté
alors il y a du bon et du mauvais mais
il y a peut-être du bon c'est à dire
qu'on peut plus mettre des frontières
telles que les les gens ne voient pas ce
qui se passe ailleurs quoi oui oui
mais il faut faire attention
un exemple pour d'autres quoi exactement
mais il faut faire que attention parce
que j'ai un système rien
j'ai du mal à m'exprimer
ce livre c'est que nous on bien sûr on a
l'habitude de se liberté on baigne
dedans mais elles sont pas tombées comme
ça et tous ces hommes qui se sont battus
pour qu'on est ces libertés montrent à
quel point c'est fragile et que voilà
l'issue d'un combat n'est jamais
effectivement
la liberté de croire au Père Noël
pour les enfants écoutez merci merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre je rappelle
alors des hommes des femmes de liberté
de l'oral maki Nathalie Wolf Elsa Auriol
et poncho voilà vous étiez trois sur
quatre on embrasse Laura
et puis et puis Raphaël
Raphaël Costa le procès du Père Noël
condamnerez-vous le Père Noël voilà vous
achetez le livre vous devez déjurer
deux livres absolument
aux étudiants merci beaucoup et merci
beaucoup merci pour votre numéro de PAF
[Musique]